all right
in english this was the first thing that
turned all of our heads
jan uh
jan plays a different move than we all
predicted on move one
yeah i think it was a good choice uh he
looked like he was ready
in these c4 lines it looked like he knew
um knew pretty much what to do
and it also threw magnus off a bit
because i think everyone around the
world was predicting e4
jan hadn't shown much flexibility both
with his white repertoire and with his
black repertoire in previous games so we
thought he was just sticking to his guns
but instead he went for uh for an
entirely different approach
one that i think worked pretty well yeah
and
yeah magnus the other surprise was that
magnus played
a very sharp and unusual line rather
than taking on c4 at some moment
leading to
somewhat more simplified and balanced
positions he chose the most aggressive
ambitious approach but one which also
gives
white a great amount of possibility to
play for an advantage yep
well in the game we got that that
double-edged type of position you're
talking about with a benoni structure if
you will for those who want to look up
the benoni chess opening you can just
google or do so at chess.com openings
but it's important because this position
on the board after d3 knight f6 knight
bd2 a5 robert is one that you can see
with colors reversed all of the bononi
but also was already very critical and
had a lot of forcing lines ahead yeah
the colors reverse is key here because
white gets an extra tempo so when white
one goes knight to b3 you're attacking
the bishop on c5 kicking it back to the
e7 square and then we saw a white strike
with e3 so suddenly the position is
opening up white has this light square
bishop has already castled so for the
time being it should be at least a
slight edge for the white pieces and
arguably it was a slight edge for the
white pieces after d takes e3 again in
real time we spent some time
highlighting uh why the moves e5
traditional bononi type of moves don't
work i'll summarize fabi's points very
quickly with saying that among other
things ideas where the rook comes to e1
and the bishop comes to f4 with knight
e5 ultimately leave this d-pawn a little
tender here and black has to be very
careful before opening and extending the
center because of that the trade
occurred and already after bishop e3
we're looking position where we started
to likewise then magnus uncorks the the
surprising and very very direct knight
g4
yeah i think we were expecting magnus to
castle i'd go for a slightly slower type
of position knight to g4 suggested to me
that he was sort of ready for this
position
but it's it's
unclear even now to me how ready he was
because although
he was playing a very unusual line one
where you would expect him to be
prepared for a very risky line as well
he still got
into some danger and he was burning time
on the clock yep so
jan i think responded very accurately
and naturally
and then yeah bishop to c5 we were
expecting these moves to come yep all
the moves that were played in the game
pretty much up to knight to c5 we were
sort of expecting it and then we weren't
sure what would magnus do because he had
a lot of
interesting
options e5 was one of them
and
y plays rook to e1 black plays works to
d8
we weren't sure what was going on here
we suspected that it was dangerous for
black because of this
fascinating b4 move yep
but it's hard to say of course because
everything's hanging in the center
there's
three
you know three pawns that are
well the b-pawn the d-pawn the e-pawn
the a-pawn four pawns which are kind of
hanging
and many ways to capture them black can
capture b4 in two different ways which
is unusual
so we weren't sure about this but magnus
went for a different approach well
ultimately maybe he also agreed with the
fact that this was risky because of the
looseness of the a4 pawn is perhaps why
he played the forcing variation a3
but this moment here
again leads us to the the first critical
moment that is very relevant in terms of
what is proving to be the critical
storyline of this match it wasn't that
yon played b takes a3 robert but also
that he played it so quickly and in
hindsight it gave away all of white's
advantage it really did because the move
b4 pushing through and away from that
pawn it defends the knight on c5 which
is critical in many of these tactical
positions where white was gonna have
that pawn captured a sacrifice from
blackside to get the knight on c5 so b4
would defend it if knight takes b4 which
looks like a free pawn all sorts of rook
b1 ideas getting the b7 pawn and now you
split black's queen side pawns as the
endless taking on a2 loses the knight of
course and if the knight had retreated
down goes b7 and there were tactics
after rook b8 knight a5 which looked
very interesting and actually if we go
through that real quick knight b7 rook
b8 knight a5 you can't take on b1
because of knight takes c6 that's a
really nice tactic you can't take on a5
because you lose your rook on b8 and if
you play bishop d7 something bobby and i
talked about during one of the breaks
maybe white just plays knight to b3 and
you look at the pawn structure black has
c7 and a3 white has pawns that are
coordinated connects in the center and
white has much more space to work with
and these were the type of lines we were
not only maybe expecting but kind of
hoping we would get right because uh
obviously everyone at that point i think
was looking forward to maybe a victory
today by the challenger something to
keep this match close um yfon also
suggested while she was with us just
shout out to hoey fawn suggested nice
ideas where you actually kick the knight
and bring the knight to e5 which is also
tricky for black to deal with long term
uh specifically actually if knight h6
sorry rook to b1 our move again but if
the knight went to f6 ifan's idea 95 is
actually very strong and you see how
hard it is to deal with this b-pawn
under fire and the fact that things like
rook b1 are still coming so
those are the types of things we thought
we might see we have been looking at
these ideas a lot
not not to be yon played b takes a3
and immediately we saw that eval bar set
itself at 5050 and kind of not change
really for the rest of the game black's
moves were natural it played rook to d8
to attack the d-pawn
the knight retreated itself magnus
brought his knight back to safety and
then once that a3 pawn was gobbled by
the queen
i think we all knew that this was uh
this was going to be very difficult for
yon to create any more chances i think
that we can point to b4 as the first
critical moment in the game b takes a3
rather than b4 yeah we were excited
about yon's
chances to
push for an initiative it remains a very
sharp position but that would definitely
put the pressure on magnus
we have to remember that magnus was
getting low on time it didn't play a
factor in the game because his decisions
at some point became easy but it could
have played a very important factor if
he had been given more difficult
decisions
possibly at that moment
and
i think that was a moment that jan
rushed a bit b takes a3 was played in
five minutes
probably not enough time to
fully work out the complexities of a
position
the next few moves were natural it's
still a balance right you see it's it's
roughly equal but we highlighted the
the storyline of the game as white has
some long-term pawn weaknesses but but
needs to really make sure this bishop
can eventually cash in maybe there would
be
long-term outside past pawn chances
that that sort of came to pass after
queen e2 h6 h4 we saw bishop d7 95 again
another line suggested by ifan a very
strong maneuver by magnus carlsen to
complete development
but after queen to e3
queen to b4 and the forcing lines that
occurred with the b7 pawn falling well
we shouldn't mention this one moment
after d takes e5 yeah
magnus blundered queenie one and he said
that he didn't see it he said that after
the game to eon that he blundered this
move yeah so he was lucky that
that the blunder didn't really change
the valuation of the position so much
although it feels like knight to d7 was
the right move here the move we were
mainly looking at yep knight to g4 is
both an interesting move but also
a risky one because knight is better on
g4
as in it's more aggressively placed it's
also potentially trapped so this was an
interesting moment
um
magnus admitting the blunder was also
interesting
but we kind of suspected that maybe
queen one was missed because you you
said he looked surprised after queen won
well i think robert said it and also it
was such a
it's a retreating move right robert
talks about that a lot even at the
highest levels it's a move you you take
for granted and and
as the queens were traded in b7 fell
getting to that critical moment robert
take us through again the chances that
white maybe could have had here if not
for the the final blunder heard around
the world yeah because right now it's
white that's up a pawn but black has the
activity attacking a2 c4 and e5 so we're
thinking if c5 is in the game that's not
a great decision so maybe knight to c5
was a better choice giving up the c4
pawn and after rook to c1 really either
rook it will likely transpose into the
line black gets e5 white pushes the pawn
to a4 and it's a position where the pond
quality is more important than upon
quantity and here it may be level but
that a4 pawn is super dangerous combined
with the bishop on b7 and so black is
the one who has to fight for a draw
despite being material ahead note that
ideas like c6 now are just ridiculous
because trapping the bishop is is
actually right where that bishop wants
to be as the a palm would rush up the
board so
it was it was this position right here
it was this moment
um and
yawn played c5
yeah c5 was terrible if we back up one
move to discuss whether or not jan had
chances here
i i think the the one thing that we
overlooked was after knight c5 black is
not obligated to take that pawn and in
fact rook to a5
feels like it probably keeps the balance
completely
so
that's why i think the players were
discussing after the game the move f3
instead of knight to c5
now e5 is no longer attacked knight to
h6 is forced the knight has to drop back
and now they move bishop to e4 they
mentioned and that move actually
contains the idea of knight to c5
because that knight can potentially jump
into b7
or it contains the slower idea of rook
edc1 followed by knight to c5
and maybe this was actually jan's best
chance it's interesting that both of the
players after the game were talking
about this position so they both kind of
honed in on this idea of bishop dropping
back to e4
it also has the huge advantage of
well your bishop's never getting trapped
again
yeah on e4 it gets out of the danger
zone
and controls f5 and if we take this pawn
we start to have to calculate very
forcing ideas where a4 wants to come not
not quite right away because the bishop
but why may trade rooks first would
rookie easy one and then or rook to c1
and then
slowly but surely try to push that a
pawn down the board because now it's no
longer covered by a rook it's still
covered by a bishop but a bishop is not
a very reliable defender yep things like
knight c5 to support a4 note that there
is no rook a8 here to go corral the apon
which is which is really huge in fact
black's inability to to coordinate a
proper defense could have spelled
disaster for the world champion but alas
it was not meant to be
because
regardless of how he got there we don't
know why we've said enough criticism in
real time of whether it is
playing too fast trying to blitz magnus
not not being as focused as he should be
young played the move c5 and magnus's
facial expression
instantly said it all along with the
eval bar that was a blunder the game's
over the game because as soon as black
played c6 which honestly is quite an
easy move to miss and jan and max were
discussing this without the pawn on c5
for white white has to move knight to c5
so the pawn actually blocks the knight
square which means the bishop is
entrapped it's stuck it's not getting
out and magnus won that pawn actually
won the bishop and then won the game in
short order
as we pointed out in in real time with
some some fun uh comparisons so how it
feels to to combine all your errands
into one it's not even that black picks
up the bishop it's that the pieces
coordinate along the way and rook to b6
to give credit was a was a fun little
finishing idea here it forced forced
carlson to be super accurate
fun to point out that if you don't take
the rook white will play a5 and cement
the rook and then then we could really
be talking about some interesting
interesting dynamics but magnus was as
as accurate as ruthless as ever in his
pursuit of converting his extra piece
here especially in this position where
instead of playing quickly he paused
and realized that you know what as odd
as this looks i can afford to grab a
pawn even with a strong a pawn on this
side of the board yeah he calculated
knight takes g3 till the end
knight d4 would have also won but
prolonged the game
and
yeah it's impressive that
magnus rather than going for the safe
option yep went for the slightly riskier
looking option one where
you know we even saw lines where black
could potentially lose if you
miscalculate something right but of
course he calculated everything
till the very end
and there was never a chance for the
challenger
c5 a brilliant an important move
speaking of an accurate move that must
be found in order to justify knight
takes g3 giving up that pawn opens up
the bishop for defense
we had a lot of fun
looking for ways that white might win
this game but ultimately after rook to
a8
the pawn is stopped the bishop will come
in to help defend this knight will
continue to gobble up pawns on this side
of the board and it was enough for
yanupomnichi to throw in the towel
and arguably resign his chances to
become the next world chess champion
okay it's not over yet a three-game
deficit is not impossible in the next
five games
but dare we say it
is quite improbable that we might be
seeing a new world champion by the end
of this year
in case you didn't see our partners at
coinbase are sponsoring chess.com
coverage of the 2021 feed a world
championship and boy are we thankful
whether you're an experienced trader
been doing this for years or just
thinking about making your first crypto
purchase coinbase is the place to go
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account today
[Music]
you